I think the biggest thing that I'm
learning in this moment with launching
my own brand is that being able to
approach it very curiously is a very
important way to be as an entrepreneur
this is a huge learning process for me
and I'm literally learning as I go
[Music]
I've just always had such an obsession
with skin care and growing up my mom and
my grandma always had an obsession with
skin care and beauty and I feel like
they really Infuse That Into Me growing
up so as I got older and when I started
modeling and working in that industry I
felt like I really started to learn a
lot more about skin care and Beauty
through working with different makeup
artists and estheticians and facialists
and so many people who are experts in
their field and I feel like it really
helped me develop what My Philosophy is
on beauty and that is what really drove
me to want to start my own brand
[Music]
I think it's something that I always had
a dream of doing I just didn't really
know how to do that or where to start
and then
when the pandemic hit I felt like I had
finally
really known how I would approach
starting a beauty brand and I knew that
I wanted that to be in skin care first
and I felt like in that moment I had the
time to really pursue it and that's
where it started for me
I think my favorite part of this whole
entire process is
the creative process and that I get to
be in charge of the creative process a
lot of the time you know I've lent my
name and my face to other people's
creative process and I think that
actually has helped me develop mine in a
lot of ways but it feels very empowering
to to be the one that is in charge and I
think the thing that has prepared me
from being in the industry before is
honestly on the creative side of things
I've had the privilege of working with
so many different creatives and I think
that each time I've worked with somebody
new I've absorbed you know their energy
and I've gotten to see the way that they
work and I think that if you allow
yourself to be a sponge then you absorb
that information and you can pour it
into your own creative process
the most surprising part about this for
me so far has honestly been the response
that I've seen since launching the brand
the last two restocks we've had of our
peptide glazing fluid sold 24 units per
second and we've had a wait list of over
600 000 people
I think that when you are
launching a brand baby you have so many
hopes for it and you know you have a lot
of dreams for what the response might be
but you don't really know until it's out
there in the world and people get their
hands on your product and give honest
feedback and I've been very very
overwhelmed in the in the most positive
way by the feedback and I feel really
really grateful for that
when we were creating our goals and
putting together kind of the Pyramid of
what is the most important thing for me
when creating this these products it's
been you know effective efficacious
great packaging really having people
feel like they are having an experience
with the products it's really resonating
with people and that was my biggest goal
with the brand that when they got their
hands on the products they would really
actually love the packaging that they
would actually love the physical product
inside that it would be effective and
really be just a great product all
around I think social media is a huge
resource and it's huge for building a
brand in this moment in time and the
response from from everything from Tick
Tock from Instagram has been really
really positive which I'm really really
happy about and just the beauty
community in general especially on Tick
Tock and especially on Instagram the
fact that they have embraced it the way
that they have is just really special to
me and I could not be doing this without
the people who
have spoken about the products and
really love them
foreign
it's never going to go perfectly and
there's always going to be bumps along
the way there's always going to be
mishaps and I think my goal is to
continuously be a curious person in the
space because it only helps your brand
get better and better when you learn
from the mistakes and move forward
[Music]